the war in Ukraine has changed a lot
here for Dmitry who asked us to protect
his identity the greatest fear is being
called up to serve in the army he left
Russia for Kazakhstan but didn't stay
long uh yeah
I was gone for four months it was my
longest time away from home being in a
foreign country is hard especially when
you have no support the cost of housing
and food increased a lot it became very
expensive to live so I decided to come
back home
Dimitri is still planning to leave but
he's not sure when or where he'll go
it's still on my mind it's hard when you
don't know what's coming tomorrow some
of my friends have already left some are
planning to go so in fact there will be
very little to keep me here
thousands of young Russians have similar
stories
international team and I can't work from
Russia because
um no payment you know about no payment
with bank system of Russia so it's a big
problem
the ministry of digital development puts
the number of people who have left at
one hundred thousand but says eighty
percent of them are working remotely for
Russian companies because some people
left some people came back and it will
take
um actually a lot of time to understand
how many people actually left maybe
people who have left so they're not just
Junior Specialists they're middle Senior
Specialists and will take years upon
years of experience for the newcomers on
the markets to fill in the gap the
government is considering various
proposals incentives are on the table as
are threats to confiscate the property
of those who have left
The Brain Drain isn't new in Russia but
the war has shaped the plans of many
young professionals that is a feeling of
unease and they say us prospects are so
uncertain here they'll follow their
career path to other countries Moscow